Welcome. We are reconvening from closed session. In closed session the board discussed or took
action on the following legal matters. Mirabelli versus Olson. And we have the public comment
slide up for our waiver discussion. I'd like to take up the waiver consent items W1 through
W11. We'll now open the phone line for the public comment queue. And the slide is displayed
and we'll take a moment to see if there's any public comment coming in.
If there's any public comment in the room, please line up at the microphone.
We've given a little wait time. So hearing no, is there, there's nobody on the phone?
No, there's no callers in the queue. Okay, wonderful. So after, since there's no further
public comment, I'll ask for a motion on consent waivers one through 11. May I have a motion?
Thank you. Vice President Glover-Woods, do I have a second? Member Olson. For all in
favor please say aye. Aye. Any opposed say nay. Any abstentions? What are you doing over
there?
Motion carries. Thank you. Item 11 is the consideration of requests for determination
of funding with reasonable basis mitigating circumstances as required for non-classroom
charter schools pursuant to California Education Code sections 47612.5 and 47634.2 and associated
California Code of Regulations Title V. The CDE recommends that we take the following
actions on the charter schools mitigating circumstances requests and determination of
funding requests. Approve the mitigation, mitigating circumstances requests and determination
of funding requests at 100% for 20 charter schools as you can see in attachment one.
Approve the mitigating circumstances requests and determination of funding requests at 85%
for seven charter schools as specified in attachment one. And deny the mitigating circumstances
requests and approve the determination of funding requests at the level for which they
are qualified based on their reported expenditures for seven charter schools as shown in attachment
one. And the item will be presented by Stephanie Farland and McKenna Huey of the CDE. Thank
you very much. Thank you. Good morning. This item as board president Linda Darling-Hammond
just stated includes a consideration of determination of funding requests with mitigating circumstances
for 34 charter schools. The schools presented in this item do not meet the regulatory requirements
to qualify for 100% funding for their non-classroom based instruction based on reported expenditures
and the criteria outlined in California Code of Regulations Title V. 17 of these schools
qualify for 85% funding, 13 qualify for 70% and four qualify for 0%. And just as an aside
you on consent approved all of the other funding determination requests. We had almost 200
at one time so this was a huge, huge lift for our staff to do it once it doesn't normally
work out that way. Our recommendation today is the California Department of Education
recommends that the state board take the following actions. Approve 20 charter schools funding
determination at 100%, approve seven at 85% and approve seven charter schools funding
determinations at the level of funding for which they qualify to receive. At its April
18, 2023 meeting the advisory commission on charter schools move to recommend that
the SBE approve all schools funding determinations at 100% for two years. That motion passed
by a vote of six to two. And then to give you the background and go over the item in
more detail I passed it off to McKenna Huey. Good morning President Darling-Hammond, Vice
President Glover Woods and members of the state board. As Stephanie Farlin just said
my name is McKenna Huey and I'm a manager in the charter schools division. I'm going
to provide a little bit of background about the funding determination process. So pursuant
to California Education Code section 47612.5 a charter school may receive funding for its
non classroom based instruction only if a determination of funding is made by the state
board. If a charter school's total average daily attendance is less than 80% classroom
based it must obtain a determination of funding from the board in order to receive funding
for its non classroom based instruction. So Senate Bill 820 which was signed by the governor
in September of 2020 made changes to the funding determination process for fiscal years 2020
and 2021 through 2021-22 and this impacted charter schools that had an active funding
determination that expired on June 30th of 2021 and 2022. So specifically this bill extended
the deadline for non classroom based charter schools to submit a funding determination
renewal quest from February 1st to June 30th. Pursuant to this bill non classroom based charter
schools that submitted a complete funding determination request by the June 30th deadline
received their current level of funding for two years and these funding determination
requests did not require approval from the state board. So the department worked very
closely with those charter schools who were impacted by Senate Bill 820 to ensure that
all charter schools submitted a complete funding determination request by the deadline. So
for both fiscal years all schools who were required to submit by June 30th submitted
by that date and therefore received their current level of funding for two additional
years. Due to the impact of this bill on the funding determination process for the last
couple of fiscal years the advisory commission on charter schools as well as the state board
have heard significantly fewer funding determination requests than in previous years. However as
this bill does not apply for fiscal years 2022, 2023 and beyond the department anticipates
that the state board will return to hearing a large volume of funding determination requests
particularly at the main meeting and as Stephanie Farlin just said we had over 200 or close
to 200 requests that we processed this year. So as stated in this item education code section
47634.3 provides that regulations shall specify that a non-classroom based instruction is
conducted for the instructional benefit of pupils and is substantially dedicated to that
function. So in determining the amount of funding to be allocated to a charter school
for its non-classroom based instruction the state board shall consider among other factors
it deems appropriate the amount of the charter schools total budget expended on certificate
employee salaries and benefits and on school sites as well as the teacher to pupil ratio
of the school. This section also states that for the 2003-2004 fiscal year and each fiscal
year thereafter the amount of funding determined by the state board shall be no more than 70%
of the unadjusted amount to which a charter school would otherwise be entitled unless
the state board determines that a greater or lesser amount is appropriate based on the
criteria outlined in education code.
So regulations specify and outline the eligibility requirements for specific levels of funding
for charter schools offering non-classroom based instruction. So as illustrated on the
table on this slide the requirements to qualify for a recommendation for 100% funding are
for non-classroom based instruction is charter schools spending 40% of their public revenues
on certificate salaries and benefits, 80% of their total revenues on instruction related
services and maintain a pupil to teacher ratio of 25 to 1.
For charter schools that do not meet the requirements and criteria for their requested level of
funding regulation states that a reasonable basis also referred to as a mitigating circumstance
by which to make an other recommendation in order to allow a non-classroom based charter
school to receive a higher percentage of funding than it qualifies for based on its expenditures
may be found.
So getting into the actual item now as previously stated this item considers determination of
funding requests for 34 charter schools. All of these charter schools fail to meet the
requirements to qualify for 100% funding for their non-classroom based instruction.
When considering mitigating circumstances the department is guided by regulations section
1196.3.4E and considers the unique or exceptional circumstances of the charter school. This
section of regulations provides specific instances for which mitigating circumstances may be
considered which include but are not limited to information provided by the school on its
funding determination form, documented data regarding individual circumstances of the
charter school, the size of the charter school and the number of years a charter school has
been in operation.
This section also states that serious consideration of full funding shall be given to charter
schools with less than a total of 100 units of prior year second period average daily
attendance and charter schools that are in their first year of operation.
California code of regulations title 5 section 1196.3.4B permits the department to ask charter
schools for additional information in order to make possible a more detailed review or
to develop a reasonable basis for a recommendation other than those prescribed by regulations.
Pursuant to this section the department requests and considers additional information of charter
schools which may include but again is not limited to charter schools excess reserves
as well as their previous requests for the consideration of mitigating circumstances.
With specific regard to a charter schools excess reserves regulations state that reserves
in excess of the greater of $50,000 or 5% of total expenditures may be allowed for economic
uncertainties or long-term expenditures such as capital projects if the excess reserves
are satisfactorily explained.
Pursuant to this section during the consideration of requests for mitigating circumstances the
department does ask for additional information of charter schools excess reserves and the
department's review and consideration of that additional information is limited to
what is provided by the charter schools.
Pursuant to regulations the funding period for an existing non-classroom based charter
school shall be for a minimum of two years and a maximum of five years in length.
As outlined in statute five year periods are dependent on a charter schools academic performance
index rate however because API is no longer calculated the department does not currently
recommend five year periods.
For charter schools requesting the consideration of mitigating circumstances it is the department's
practice to recommend funding periods of two years and this allows the department to timely
revisit schools funding determinations and ensure that they are meeting the requirements
outlined in regulations for approved level of funding.
Schools whose funding determinations are approved at a level different than what is requested
may submit a funding determination reconsideration request pursuant to regulations.
Pursuant to this section a school that wishes to seek a higher or lower determination of
funding shall do so by filing a new determination of funding request during the effective period
of their funding determination and if approved by the state board that would replace their
funding determination that is then in effect.
Based on its review of the charter schools reported expenditures and in alignment with
the requirements outlined in regulations the department recommends that the state board
approve 20 schools funding determination requests at 100% which is a higher level of funding
than for which they qualify.
Approve seven charter schools funding determination requests at 85% which again is a higher level
of funding than for which they qualify.
Approve seven charter schools funding determinations at the level of funding for which they qualify
to receive based on their expenditures and regulations and to clarify the department
is not proposing that these schools have their funding cut or that these schools receive
no funding for their non-classing based instruction rather the department is recommending that
the state board approve these schools funding determinations at the level for which they
qualify to receive pursuant to regulations.
Thank you for your consideration of this item I'm happy to answer any questions.
So at this point I want to ask our liaisons Vice President Glover-Woods and member Olken
if they have any initial comments while we're putting up the public comment slide could
you go ahead and put that up great.
So if there are comments to be called in please use the number and the participant access
code on this slide and Vice President Glover-Woods will you start us off.
I'm actually going to have member Olken start us off and I will follow her if that is okay.
Thank you.
So first I just want to point out that you both mentioned the incredible amount of information
you had to review for this item and having tried to keep up with it myself I just want
to thank you for how much you looked at and reviewed it was an incredible volume of information
and as the course of this between ACCS and now there's been new information that's been
presented and they kept going back so I just want to thank you for that too.
And then just for us what you heard was that we are considering two different recommendations
there's the recommendation coming from the department which is outlined in the item and
then at the advisory commission on charter schools there was a different recommendation
which is also outlined in the slides and there was quite a bit of discussion about this item
the mitigating circumstances are basically related to arguments about pandemic effect
and one-time funding and how that plays out for schools as they're trying to determine
their budgets so it really was a meaty conversation and I'm sure we're going to hear
a lot about it in public comment so and I'll save the rest for later thank you.
And I will just add to member Olkins comments by stating what was we just saw in the conclusion
and recommendation chart just again to re-emphasize that this item is not bringing forward no funding
all of the charter schools would what is being recommended is that they either receive the funding
determination at the level for which they are qualified to receive or above that particular
level and so I just want to underscore that as well as underscoring there is opportunity as was
shared in one of our previous slides for any school that receives a funding determination
at a level that they are that they qualify for but they feel they should receive more
they do have opportunity to come back and request an additional consideration for additional funding
so again just wanted to underscore those two points as we get ready to go into public comment.
So I guess we want to see first if there's any public comment in the room
will the following individuals please line up at the microphone
Cynthia Rachel, Nicholas Watson, Heidi Gasca, Joe Cerreira, Eric Premack, Jeff Rice and Bill Dodson.
I think you can go ahead please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Please be sure the microphone is on. Is it better now? Better yeah thank you. My name is
Cynthia Rachel and I'm representing South Sutter and Sky Mountain charter schools. Our schools have
a track record of clean audits, fiscal solvency and 100 funding determinations for more than 15
years. I'm concerned that the recommendations by made by the ACCS are not the ones that were
presented as the formal recommendation for your review today. There are now new recommendations
that are not following the regulatory process outlined by SB 740. This discrepancy has caused
significant distress to our schools as well as all mentioned in item 11. We were encouraged by
ACCS's recognition of the one-time unique and exceptional circumstances that all schools in
California have faced over the past three years which prevented us from meeting the usual funding
thresholds. The ACCS's recommendation offers a fair and just solution for our schools considering
these exceptional circumstances. Please support the ACCS's recommendation. Thank you.
Hello my name is Heidi Gasca. I'm the executive director for Excel Academy charter school.
I wouldn't be here today if it wasn't for the extraordinary one-time circumstances brought
about by the COVID pandemic. The tremendous uncertainty and fear and doubt was not a time
conducive to make haste decisions in regards to budgeting. As a steward of public funds I was
committed to be prudent during in the budgeting process. In fact the timing of the required SB
740 filing artificially inflated our reserves and the reality is we did not have access to
the necessary funds during the course of the 21-22 school year. Excel Academy fell above the 40%
and just 3% below the 80% target. I want to make sure that you are aware that Excel Academy was
just one of 11 non-classroom based charter schools that was named a 2023 California distinguished
school. In fact we were the only school to be given this honor in the entire high desert.
We would like to continue to educate students who attend one of the top
356 schools in California. Acknowledge for closing the achievement gap and
achieving exceptional student performance.
Good morning board president Dr. Doldrum and board members. Thank you for the opportunity
that to speak with you today. My name is Joe Sarara from Excel Academy charter school. One
of the distinguished schools selected in 2023. The COVID-19 pandemic has posed significant
challenges for our school this year and last in the last two years. In the last fiscal year we
faced financial difficulties due to unforeseen events because of the influx of students that
chose our schools but we couldn't claim funding for those because of SB 579. We also receive
$290,000 in PPP program which later forgiven which impacted our SB 740 calculation
and artificially inflated our reserve. So in conclusion I express my sincerest gratitude
for the opportunity to address the state board of education and shed light in on our circumstances.
I strongly urge the state board of education to accept the recommendation from ACCCS
and approve 100% funding for Excel Academy charter school. Thank you.
Good morning my name is Bill Dobson and I'm the director at Motivated Youth Academy. Motivated
Youth Academy has an enrollment of 251 students and has been a dashboard alternative school status
community of practice since July 2019. Our school is one of only three dot schools in our service
area that is primarily virtual meaning students get the benefit of both in-person support from
a credentialed teacher as well as the flexibility of virtual program offers. Our teachers go into
the communities where students live and meet with them weekly at public locations such as libraries,
community centers, and tribal halls. Our focus is on creating equitable access to consistently
strong outcomes for all students paying special attention to the social emotional needs of
historically marginalized populations. I urge you to recommend 100% full funding for Motivated Youth
Academy so the at-promise and opportunity youth we serve continue to have equitable access to
public education and the opportunity to earn a high school diploma. Thank you.
Morning members of the board. Nicholas Watson speaking on behalf of the California
Charter Schools Association. I just wanted to thank CDE staff. I know that it took a tremendous
amount of work to review all these materials and then we just wanted to say we support
full funding determinations for all these schools consistent with the ACCS recommendation. Thank you.
Good morning. Jeff Rice with the A plus personalized learning network association. I want
to commend the ACCS's wisdom and compassion in recommending 100% funding for two years
for all 34 charter schools having to rely on mitigating circumstances and urge you to
approve the ACCS recommendation as well to allow these schools time to return to normal
post-pandemic operations without undermining their funding stability. It is critically important to
recognize and acknowledge the COVID pandemic as the most extreme and extraordinary mitigating
circumstance in our lifetime as ample justification to grant all these schools 100% funding for two
years. Fiscal year 21-22 is the first year coming out of the eye of the pandemic storm was dominated
by continuing fear, uncertainty, and doubt about a very unclear future not to mention extreme
challenges around teacher shortages, chronic student absences, mental health issues, and more
all beyond the control of any school administration. It was not a climate conducive to a return to
normal operations yet nor to engage in major spending commitments but instead require
prudent and responsible measures internally to ensure higher than normal reserves to maintain
stability. I urge you to approve the recommendation of the ACCS. Thank you.
Good morning. Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center here in support of
the ACCS recommendation for full funding. The law here is poorly drafted and folks can read it in
different ways. I was a party to the negotiations roughly 20 years ago that led to the creation of
this law and we had long discussions with the governor at the time Gray Davis and he shared some
of our concerns about the law and when he signed it he wrote a signing message that went along with
it and you can download it from his archives and he said because I have some concern that this bill
could be administered in an overly broad fashion I'm requesting the state board of education to
regulate and administer the provisions of this act in a manner to affect only those charter schools
who spend excessively on administration and profit. None of the schools before you today
do we have evidence of excessive spending on administration nor profit. All of them have
submitted perfectly valid reasons for mitigation, standard practices that all school districts and
charter schools routinely engage in and I hope that you will support the ACCS recommendation. Thank you.
And we do not have any callers in the queue so that concludes public comment for item number 11.
Okay at this point I think we're open for board discussion and questions so
let's kick that off. I do have a question which is and maybe our liaisons can
help and or our CDE colleague can help. Can you articulate for me why the ACCS recommendations
were not adopted? Could you mind just start us off with that? Sorry to clarify you're asking
why the CDE did not adopt the ACCS's recommendation? The CDE just upon its analysis of all the
school's funding determination requests and mitigating circumstances we feel that our
recommendation is appropriate and what the school is qualified for. We did take mitigating circumstances
into consideration and as you'll see on the item and in our analysis we do acknowledge that.
There were other considerations though that led us to recommend other levels of funding that
they would receive so 85 percent or 70 percent.
So then I want to know what the other considerations were that would
sort of push aside the mitigating circumstances. Okay and those were also outlined in the item.
A lot of the things that we or the other things that we considered were the charter school's
reserves. Regulations does state that a charter school may have more than five percent in reserves
if they are satisfactorily explained. We did ask for more information of those charter schools who
had very large reserves and as you'll see they ranged anywhere from 20 percent to 80 percent to
100 percent of their total expenditures and so we did ask for that information. If we felt that
their responses were not satisfactory again we made our recommendation as we felt was appropriate.
Are you yes Vice President Glover Woods. I just had a follow-up question. As it relates to one
time funding that has been received and how was that taken into consideration
with reserves and with the impact it would have on the percentages that are required.
Absolutely and that is something that we considered as well. A part of our recommendations were
we came to our recommendations because if we excluded those one-time funds from the school's
calculations they still would not meet the requirements to qualify for a recommendation
of 100 percent funding. So in cases where those one-time funds did impact their ability to meet
or qualify for meet those requirements again we did find that to be a mitigating circumstance
but in situations where had that one-time funding been excluded and they still would have not met
the requirements we made a recommendation as we felt was in alignment with regulations.
I just wanted to provide one more piece of information for your question.
There were and if I get this wrong please feel free to correct me. There were two schools
who CDE did change their recommendation for between ACCS and now so upon further review
they changed their recommendation to full funding so there and that was based on more
information that came in and that's correct right excellent and then my reading of the
recommendations for less than full funding was almost in most cases it was based on the
what schools said their reserves would be used for and why or didn't and
so that's just trying to answer your question and then it can I go on to a comment then?
Okay thanks and then in as I sort of dug into this what I sort of what what stood out to me was
the schools who I mean first of all there were so many schools and it was a lot because of the
the gap in doing these in doing these funding determinations and during that gap
that was when we were in the depths of uncertainty related to the pandemic and
that was both about how many students schools had some of these schools their enrollment dropped
some of these schools their enrollment actually increased substantially but because of the hold
harmless legislation they didn't receive increased funding for those students so they
were actually educating more students with the same per pupil funding and there was also the
time period in which what schools could expect to see in terms of state funding whether it was
one-time funding ongoing funding categorical funding things it was really unclear at the
time of budget decision making and so the position I think these schools are in is
their funding going forward is dependent upon their previous year's budget revenue and expenses
and so trying to fit within the sort of funding formula was particularly complicated
in this time of great uncertainty and so I think when the schools requested mitigating circumstances
that's what it was about right it was like this is what instead of continuing to instead of
decreasing the amount of per pupil funding we're going to have in the future based on the
future based on the uncertainty of the last couple years they're requesting that their funding stays
the same and to me that's sort of the the crux of the issue and it was also really the crux of the
conversation at the accs where the cd is carefully and and conscientiously reviewing information that
came in and the schools are also trying to figure out how to continue to do right by their kids
coming out of a really uncertain time
Any Vice President Glover-Woods? We're going back and forth here I just want to
shape into context I believe what is in front of us in this particular item and and please again
McKenna correct me if I'm incorrect we're looking at our 14 schools that have not
in this particular item been recommended for 100% funding and just to underscore the conversation
that took place at the accs meeting the commissioners at the meeting those who
voted in the affirmative to go with 100% funding for two years felt that the impact of the pandemic
the impact of one-time funds the impact of many of these different things that we could have never
anticipated has directly impacted the schools and what and the mitigating circumstances that
they have submitted for so again just trying to stick with the context of what we're looking at
and we have 14 schools that are being presented before us to be recommended at a level lower
than the 100% two-year full funding even though they're being recommended at the level of funding
for which they qualify I do have one question as I went into that long dissertation and I apologize
one question for the 14 schools that we're considering not 100% funding for the two years
are any of those schools in a sense of going to receive less funding than they previously had
because of the mitigating circumstance funding determination they've submitted now
that is that sorry can is the microphone working um that is a possibility I don't have that
historical information on me right now so I can't give you kind of that side by side of all the
schools and what they previously had but that definitely is a possibility as stated in a
previous slide again schools can submit every consideration request if they receive a different
level of funding them for which they qualified for and I'd also like to go back to something
that member Olken that you stated so you spoke a lot about the circumstances of COVID and the
one-time funding in the pandemic and just to clarify the CDE did take those things into
consideration you'll see that in the item as well as in our analysis for each school
there were other factors outside of those circumstances that guided us to our other
recommendation that wasn't 100% funding for their non-classroom based instruction
I was just going to clarify that there are definitely some schools we heard in public
comment who they would receive less they have received 100% funding previously and the
recommendation is to receive less than 100% currently so just to answer that your question
are there other questions or comments
clarifying question there's a school that spends more than 100%
percent on certificated staff compensation how does that happen
so in terms of calculating percent is spent on certificated salaries and benefits
that is looked at based on a school's public revenues and I instruction related services
are based on total revenues
any other comments or questions
do I have a motion
is there more deliberation needed
that's okay just based on something you just said and the question
vice president clever woods asked so some schools may receive less funding and you're funding them
at what they qualified for so the less funding would mean difficulty going forward is that
what your intent is your intent with the concern about the reserves your intent is that they use
the reserves going forward if they use less funding or what is the intent that what is the
nexus between the reserves and the lack of of lower funding than what they received before
if that makes sense I think I understand so there is no intent to cut these schools fundings again
we are guided by regulations and based on the expenditures that these schools reported to us
this is what they qualify to receive for their non-classroom based instruction again pursuant
to regulations okay so again just to kind of form context for the motion and for the decision that
the board will need to make we have CDE's recommendation that outlines as we see on
the slide before us and then the ACCS has in a sense recommended that the state board consider
providing 100 funding for two years for all of the schools in this particular item
um as a result of a lot of the different things that have been talked about so that's what I see
as the two points before us at right now and don't know if there's more conversation about
those two options or how we want to move forward from there
Member Olken you're you were leaning in you are our liaison so we rely to you we rely on you
I mean I'm I'm prepared to make a motion um and I guess we can I mean my my the motion I would
I would like to make is that we um approve these schools at 100 funding all of them for two years
at 100 funding all of them for two years as recommended by the ACCS
and do I have a second for that motion
I'll second it but we're weighing and balancing here is the mitigating circumstances and the
regulations which were enacted when there weren't mitigating circumstances and how do we weigh and
balance those two things and we appreciate that it puts the department and everyone else into a
very complicated situation so we have a motion and we have a second is there any further discussion
of the motion uh yes member Yoshimoto Tari I just wanted you to clarify the timeline for appeals
should um the current motion on the table not pass what's the process for appeals
so a charter school may submit a reconsideration of their funding determination and they would do
that during the period that their funding determination that they want to be reconsidered
is in effect so the um current funding determinations are for fiscal year 2023-24
a charter school could submit a reconsideration request anytime during that fiscal year or really
anytime during the period for which their funding determination
and maybe I missed this by reviewing the file but how how many of these are alternative schools
I know we had one public speaker from I do not have that information on hand right now but I
can definitely look that up and get back to you I can ask one more clarifying question follow up on
that um is that if following up on a member Yoshimoto Tari's question if the motion doesn't
pass and the one that I made um and the schools choose to come back um is there so what they
submitted for this funding determination request was based on audited financials
so they would is it true that they would need to wait another year to have another round of
audited financials to submit and if that's true is the funding retroactive suggesting that
or is it in that or is the funding retroactive because if it isn't then of the two-year term
the most they could be hoping for is one year of full funding is that correct
I believe the funding can be retroactive um again during the reconsideration request schools
indicate which periods or the period of times that they want to be reconsidered so um in that
regard if it was for let's say a previous fiscal year I believe their funding would be adjusted
retroactively and the the soonest they could come back would be when they have another year
of audited financials to apply with typically that is the case um there have been circumstances
in the past where charter schools have submitted a funding determination funding determination
request based on unaudited actuals or budget data as well and again we do take that into
consideration in our review and if we need additional information then we ask for that
thank you
any other questions come at discussion before we vote
all right saying none all in favor of the motion as stated please say aye
aye any opposed nay okay two nays and motion passes thank you very much
we need to take a break at this point at this point we're going to take a
15 minute break and reconvene at 10 um 20
all right uh we're reconvening uh we have uh received thank you we've received written notice
earlier today from the charter operator of time community charter informing the state
board of education and the cde that they're surrendering their charter effective june 5th
2023 accordingly we do not need to proceed with item 13 and are pulling it from the agenda
and i just say that you know it's clear when we heard from the charter operator and the families
the children and the uh parents yesterday that this is not a failure of educational practice
it is a failure of our system and figure out how to fund the educational practice that really helps
my kids who've been falling through the cracks be supported so
we hope that there will be a way to continue the the work uh in the to the benefit of kids
in the work that goes forward whatever in whatever way in whatever district uh
context that that may uh allow for and with that we're going to move on now uh to item 14
which is um several pages hence here public comment uh so we're going to take up agenda
item 14 which is general public comment public comment is invited on any matter that is not
included on the printed agenda so members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item
may do so in person or by calling the number that is shown on what will soon be posted as a public
comment slide very good thank you very much uh you can call the number on that slide and use
the participant access code we also want to remind folks uh to turn down their speaker volume if they
are following the live feed to avoid an echo are there any speakers signed up to provide public
comment in person yes there too um steve mcdoogle and tim taylor
good morning uh members of the board board president cd staff i'm steve mcdoogle and
serendipitously as today i'm now the uh president of cft's division council of early childhood
through adult education locals and i'm representing the voice of about 50 000
educators throughout the state and i'm happy to observe you and support you in any way we can
as you implement uh carry out and sometimes enforce policy so i'll be around for a couple
years at least thank you very much welcome
is another speaker tim you're up
hi tim taylor from the california small school district association and good to see you again
and thanks for your service uh president and all i sent you guys an email about uh from fresno
county office of ed and riverside about the number of plans and templates and due dates
the districts are facing we require between 20 and 29 and on behalf of the small districts
i encourage us to have a task force or something how do we get these things to be more relevant
our l caps are between 60 and 100 pages parents are not reading them we've developed a five page
l cap that meets the statute and we welcome to work with brooks and the cde to let's do let's
do some plans that parents will read and um you're overwhelming we're all overwhelming these uh
superintendents especially a superintendent principal who's trying us to work and do the
school and you're we're making them do all these plans so i encourage you look at those templates
and uh work with us to make them more efficient and effective
that all the in-person comment so do we have uh callers on the phone uh we do we have
approximately 10 on the phone right now um i will open up the phone line right now um good morning
state board of education please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now
my name is gimme agers i am the superintendent principal of big creek elementary school
i'm calling regarding our our l cap plan i'm going to try to be very brief uh at this point
in time we have approximately 30 students we can write a more detailed individual education plan
for each student in less pages and in less time then it takes us to fill out the paperwork for
the standard california state l cap uh the number of plans that i present i could do in a much
shorter better manner where my parents would understand very well where the money is going
why it's going there and how it is affecting kids so i'm just calling to let you guys know that this
is an a very important piece that we do need that help the five page plan if you teamed it with a
10 page strategic plan would say more to parents and your community than our current l cap process
thank you very much for listening thank you next caller ending in the last four digits one two seven
nine you are now live please start your public comment hi i'm cally i am a program educator
at girls inc and i am here on behalf of our advocacy group that is advocating for student
mental health rights on campus and we it came to our attention that california senate bill number
14 was amended to include that a people shall be excused from school in the absence is due to the
benefit of the people's mental or behavioral health and we have realized that schools and districts
are not implementing this many administrators are not aware of this and have marked people unexcused
wrongfully or given inaccurate information we are asking that the sb members on the board further
discuss this issue and update illness verification to include mental health as an excuse as excusable
absence we are also asking that schools ensure that they are enforcing excuse mental health
days and are requiring education on sb14 for students also update the illness verification
regular regulations to include for the benefit of the people's mental health or behavioral health
and ensure schools request no additional requisites just as any other illness absence thank you thank
you next caller ending the last four digits 6111 you are now live please start your public comment
hello i'm gabriella moffey proud to be in my 10th year as superintendent of the award-winning
garden grove unified school district as you've read in my recent correspondence the state system
for both rewards distinguished schools and accountability differentiated assistance is deeply
flawed in respect to the dashboard element of chronic absenteeism this year both programs were
based on last year's data and eight of our schools should have received distinguished schools
but were denied due to chronic absenteeism based exclusively on COVID-19 absences
absences which were required by the state health order in respect to distinguished schools many of
our parents will share with you their extreme disappointment in the state for denying their
schools this award as they feel like the state is penalizing them for following the rules instead of
rewarding them as their children still excelled academically despite the fact that they were
required to stay home due to circumstances out of their control in respect to differentiated
assistance we had 33 schools identified for atsi none for csi but 21 of those were also solely
based on COVID-19 absences from last year i've submitted detailed written public comments for
this meeting on both of these issues and i have faith that the state will make this right for our
students families and schools thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
my name is linda wei i'm
a parent of antony elementary school in the garden girl unify school district
antony parents take great pride in our school this year we are running for the national blue
ribbon and last year we ranked in the top 20 percent of our school by u.s news and will report
we were shocked that our school did not earn the california distinguished school award based on
only on our COVID-19 absences my daughter both had COVID absence the past year that met the
chronic absenteeism criteria however our absence for both girls were due to the
state-mandated COVID requirements despite the absence of spoken stay on top of the
missed schoolwork and the grades reflect that evidence report got showed us she met our standard
and caley exceeded standard both e.l.a and math on the state aspect test our children were required
to stay home and still work very hard to stay on top of their schoolwork doesn't this doesn't the
state trust us that we only kept our children home when it was medical necessary and required by law
please do the right thing and correct your error thank you thank you
next caller you are now live please start your public comment
foreign
Hola, soy Elvia Magaa y soy madre de familia de la escuela primaria Hazard en el distrito
escolar unificado de Colorado.
Hola, soy Elvia Magaa from the primary school.
Puede repetir el nombre de la escuela, por favor?
Si quiere, yo puedo leer la traduccin en ingls.
Como usted dice, seora.
Okay, I'll read Spanish first and then English.
Hola, soy Elvia Magaa y soy madre de familia de la escuela primaria Hazard en el distrito
escolar unificado de Garden Grove.
Hazard es escuela galardonada.
Fue nombrada escuela distinguida de California en el 2020 y en el 2022 clasific en el 20%
las mejores de todas las escuelas primarias por U.S. News and World Report y recibi
el premio de oro de PBIS.
Nos sorprendi descubrir que la nica razn por la que Hazard no recibi el premio de
escuela distinguida de California este ao es por las ausencias de COVID.
A mi esposo le dio COVID en agosto de 2021 y mis hijas y yo tuvimos que permanecer en
cuarentena por 10 das.
Despus en octubre de 2021, Emily tuvo sntomas parecidos al resfriado y se le requiri tomar
otra cuarentena de 10 das.
En enero de 2022, a mis hijas y a m nos dio COVID.
Una vez ms, seguimos los protocolos y trabajamos arduamente para mantener a nuestras hijas
al da con el trabajo escolar a pesar de los das perdidos.
Me sorprendi que el estado sancionara a las escuelas al negarles este reconocimiento
cuando el estado fue quien cre los requisitos de COVID.
Hello, my name is Elvia Magaa and I'm a parent at Hazard Elementary School in the
Garden Grove Unified School District.
Hazard is an award-winning school.
We earned the California Distinguished School Award in 2020 and in 2022, we ranked in the
top 20% of all elementary schools by U.S. News and World Report and received the PBIS
Gold Award for a positive culture and climate.
We were shocked to find out that the only reason we didn't receive the California
Distinguished School Award this year is because of our COVID absences.
When my husband tested positive for COVID in August 2021, my daughters and I had to
quarantine for 10 days.
Then, in October 2021, Emily had cold-like symptoms and was required to take another
10-day quarantine.
In January 2022, my daughters and I all tested positive for COVID.
Once again, we followed the protocols.
Our family worked hard to keep up with our daughters' schoolwork despite the mis-states.
It's surprising to us that the state would punish schools by denying them this honor
when the state was the one who created the COVID requirements in the first place.
Thank you.
Next caller.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hola, mi nombre es Jacqueline Andrade.
Yo hablo espaol y ingls, so voy a empezar en espaol.
Una vez ms, mi nombre es Jacqueline Andrade y mis dos hijas asisten a la escuela primaria
Morningside en el Distrito Escolar Unificado de Garland Grove, una escuela excepcional.
Estamos orgullosos de que superamos consistentemente a otras escuelas en las pruebas estatales.
Esperbamos ser la escuela distinguida de California de 2023 como en el 2019, y nos
sorprendi mucho que el estado no nos concedi el premio debido a nuestras ausencias de COVID.
Mis hijas se vieron muy afectadas por las reglas impuestas por el estado durante la pandemia.
Mis hijas tambin se vieron obligadas a quedarse en casa por estar expuestas a una persona con COVID.
Mis hijas tuvieron ascencias justificados por haber estado en contacto con familiares con COVID.
Adems, perdieron trabajo escolar, instrucciones y a sus amigos.
An as, ambas continuaron teniendo un desempeo excepcional en sus trabajos escolares,
cumpliendo y superando todas las normas del nivel de grado.
Once again, my name is Jacqueline.
I have two daughters at 10 Morningside Elementary in the Garland Grove Unified School District,
an outstanding school.
We are proud that Morningside consistently outperforms other schools on state testing.
We expected to be a 2023 California distinguished schools like in 2019, and we're surprised
that the state didn't grant us the award because of our COVID absences.
My children were greatly affected by the rules that the state put in place during the pandemic.
My children were forced to stay home because of exposure to COVID positive person.
My daughters had excused absences, all due to being in close contact with relatives who
had COVID.
Furthermore, they missed schoolwork, instruction and their friends.
Still, they both continue to have outstanding performance in their schoolwork, meeting and
excelling at all grade level standards.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Jen, and I'm a parent at Patent Elementary School in the Garland Grove
Unified School District.
I wanted to voice my opinion, opposition to Patent being unfairly denied the 2023 California
distinguished school award due solely to our COVID-19 absences.
The state is giving out awards for school with high academic performance, and we have
that.
We hit all of the marks.
Our ELA and math score ranked very high.
Our English learner progress indicator is high, and our suspension rates are low.
Despite the challenges of COVID-19, we worked hard, but we were denied the award due to
COVID-19 absences, which were required by the state quarantine rules.
My daughter had 20 excused absences during the 2021-22 school year due to COVID-related
symptoms and being in close contact.
Despite the missed day, we worked hard to coordinate missed work from the school and
ensure that she did not fall behind in her schoolwork.
We were so proud when she met and exceeded standards on the state SBAC test.
In the end, we know our students are high achieving, and we don't need the state to
tell us so, but we certainly don't appreciate being excluded for something out of our control
that you mandated.
Thank you.
Next caller, you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Caller, you are now live.
Next caller, you are now live.
Hi.
Please start your public comment.
Go ahead.
Hi, my name is Lisa Ichikawa, and I have two sons at Excelsior Elementary School in Garden
Grove Unified School District.
When I learned that our school did not receive the California Distinguished Schools Award
because of COVID absences, I was appalled.
Excelsior earned the California Distinguished Schools Award in 2020, and our test scores
show that we should have earned it this year too.
We didn't want our sons to miss so many days of school, but we had to follow the state
guidelines.
Grant was sent home so many times for COVID-19 symptoms that he was classified as chronically
absent.
It turns out he had severe dust allergies.
When Grant also tested positive for COVID-19, both of our sons had to stay home for the
required five days and could not return until we had a negative test.
Both boys had to stay home for additional days due to being close contacts.
Their teachers did an amazing job to help them stay on track, and they continue to meet
and exceed standards.
The state should give the California Distinguished Schools to all disturbing schools, but leave
COVID-19 absences out of it.
This does not discourage all that we have accomplished academically, and the state should
know that.
Thank you.
Next caller, you're now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hi, I'm Javad Arain, a parent at Murdy Elementary School in the Gardner Grove Unified School
District, and I'm urging the state to reconsider Murdy Elementary for the California Distinguished
School Award, since the school met all criteria for this except its chronic absenteeism data,
which was due to COVID-19 absences.
In the 2021-22 school year, my daughter contracted COVID-19, which necessitated her prolonged
absence from school due to state required quarantine protocols.
Despite these circumstances, the school ensured that Sonia was provided with appropriate remote
learning opportunities to minimize the impact on her education.
My daughter's absences were directly related to a medical situation beyond our control.
The school should not be penalized for circumstances such as these, which are unforeseeable and
unavoidable.
Murdy Elementary School's rigorous academic programs, innovative teaching methods, and
inclusive culture have significantly contributed to the development and success of its students.
It should not be denied this award for following the state-mandated COVID protocols.
Thank you.
Next caller, you're now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hello, my name is Allison Tong, and my daughter attends Barker Elementary School in the Gardner
Grove Unified School District.
We recently learned that we were denied the California Distinguished Schools Award due
to our COVID absences.
This was not only extremely disappointing to our parents, but also to our staff who work
hard to help students succeed.
My daughter was a TK student last year.
She has an IEP, and we all work really hard to ensure that she is continuing to achieve
her new developmental milestones.
In fact, she is meeting grade level standards and doing well this year as a first grader,
especially since last year she suffered long COVID diagnosed by her doctor.
Emma missed a lot of school last year, but that is because she had long COVID as well
as other exposures.
The state shouldn't punish schools for following state and county health requirements and for
doing our part to slow the spread.
Thank you.
Next caller, you're now live.
Please start your public comment.
Hello, my name is Dat Sweeney, and two of my children, Timothy and Elizabeth, attend
Garden Park Elementary School in the Garden Grove Unified School District.
We were really disappointed to learn that we were denied the California Distinguished
Schools Award due to COVID absences.
It seemed wrong to punish schools where families followed the rules during COVID.
When COVID hit, it was hard on the entire family, and when my wife and I tested positive,
our children were required to stay home for 13 days of school.
It was impossible to isolate as we had to properly care for our children.
Then when our children had COVID, they missed more days.
So despite missing so much school, both Timothy and Elizabeth continued to maintain high academic
performance.
They both exceeded standards on all state tests and district benchmarks.
As their father, I'm so proud of their endurance, perseverance, and determination to earn high
academic marks during a very challenging time.
The state should remove COVID absences from its formula for measuring academic success.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item number 14.
Thank you very much, and, you know, of course, these are items that are not agendized that
we hear about, but I do want to note that we are going to hear about the chronic absenteeism
indicator in our July meeting, so we will be following up on some of the commentary
that we've just heard.
And with that, thank you.
I hereby adjourn our May 2023 meeting at 1042 a.m., and I look forward to seeing you in July.